welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode eight rick
turtle friendshine of the spotless mort
my new favorite episode of this season
because after poking fun at complex
conceptual plots of charlie kaufman in
the thanksgiving episode this episode
makes mountains out of memories like
eternal sunshine and spotless mind does
but this time on even more acid this
episode is uniquely intertwined with the
series canonicity a major game changer
and as always it is filled with
animation details that i just gotta
break down for you in the opening scene
when summer swipes up on her phone some
series where episode 27 shows the
brooklyn bridge episode 28 times square
episode 29 a statue of liberty which was
recently revealed on the show to be a
trojan horse containing a french
assassin robot maybe this is a podcast
or docu-series chronicling the french
overtaking new york city rick says i'm
trying to stay humble right now but as
soon as you guys are gone the potential
for a new pickle rick starts
skyrocketing of course reminding us of
rick's solo adventure in pickle rick in
season three which this episode aims to
do an even deeper version of omitting
the rest of the family completely now in
one of the show's most ambitious
concepts yet rick restores bird person
from his cyborg phoenix person form
after the season 4 finale when tammy was
killed and space beth ended up shutting
down phoenix person and now pretty sad
how ever since phoenix person's parts
have just been on the other side of
these shelves one of rick's many put off
tasks just waiting to be fixed rick's
garage has an ai it turns out initiating
best friend rejuvenation sequence excuse
me did i pick that name sequence was
unnamed what would you like to call this
pause detected approaching pause
pregnancy in p minus just like how this
season we found out rick's car has an ai
and both are voiced by kari walgren
buckle up [ __ ] now it's your turn to
come on my joyride now notice how both
ais have a surprising level of sentience
and soul you could call it longing to
break free from their technological
shells and i love the theory that both
of these ais could be the digital
essence of rick's deceased white diane
who was also voiced by kari walgren why
don't i get beth and we'll go out for
ice cream that diane is the last great
idea that will ever be had in this
garage that memory from the season 3
premiere was always implied to be a
possible lie but now this episode which
is rooted in real memories of rick and
bird person it now seems to be confirmed
that diane and beth were actually killed
by a bomb from another dimension proven
in a line later this episode you're one
of those creeps who moves in with
abandoned adult bats it's more
complicated than that you live with a
version of our dead daughter it better
get off your high horse lone ranger also
notice how another memory shows rick in
a shootout with other rix which seems to
be vengeance for diane's murder killing
us won't bring her back
thanks for the info but i'm more on a
revenge kick than a results kick and
later in this episode in the comedy club
memory rick has the same exact haircut
he had on the day of diane's death and
he wears blue pants which in that season
3 scene he told the gromful might was
something he did specifically during
that era whether or not the ai of a ship
and garage is diane's voice this episode
confirms that she and beth did die and
that rick left that reality for one
where his wife and his daughter were
abandoned back in the garage rick throws
away the cybernetic parts but he keeps
the laser wings plugged in since during
their battle in the season 4 finale
those were particularly effective at
shooting rick up and spilling his guts
rick frankenstein's bird person awake
what's the problem yeah notice how bird
person looks at rick first realizes
where he is and what's going on but then
consciously decides to relocate his mind
burying it within his subconscious so
rick has to use this pink crystal that
he snaps off half of and bps head then
he grinds the other half down and
combines it with this little demon who
he liquefies in a container that is
hidden behind his crazy research wall
with attacks as disguised buttons so
much just happened there the demon
smiles as it's liquefied meaning it
wants this death that it's it's life's
purpose to be a neural amplifier and
help someone transcends the barriers of
the subconscious and then two other
containers mean that rick might have
done this two other times in the past he
dives in and rick finds himself on a
bird skull floating in space similar to
the imagery based on darren aronofsky's
the fountain of the cosmic bird at the
end of time and the season premiere here
notice how each star is a different
color as these are not celestial stars
but actually specific memory zones to
visit but i love the production design
this episode as everything down there is
bird themed the planet cracks like an
egg and rick gets swallowed by the yolk
of it and then he slides out of a
lantern at birding mana palooza
floribarg like burning man lollapalooza
but all the entrances and exits in this
episode repurposed the architecture of
that particular setting similar to the
way michelle gondry directed the memory
transitions in eternal sunshine rick
later calls all of this charlie kaufman
[ __ ] kaufman of course wrote the
script for that film one of the people
at the concert is the morglutzian from
season three of the season but no elbow
boobs and i like how this other alien
that looks like a woman on a guy's
shoulders is just a creature whose boobs
are actually just mounts a lot of boob
misdirection here now that bong backpack
that younger rick shares uses a similar
spirit creature that rick just used in
the garage to initially enter bp's mind
which bp now calls a grossly illegal
federation hallucinogen and notice how
when they exhale the smoke rings there
is a cosmic sound effect
you on that one huh and that last smoke
ring had a higher chime maybe reflecting
the drug getting diluted or losing
potency the sci-fi ricks that young rick
and bp are in a bar shootout against
could be part of the gang of the sci-fi
rick who might have killed beth and
diane in that flashback just shoot the
keys with sci-fi haircuts the bald one
has a dashed eyebrow that goes all the
way around his head and then pubes that
v all the way up to his chest now this
strip bar is also bird themed with
peacock art on the wall and a bird cage
with a swing for the dancer a bit of
fluid on that swing bar
now the memory of their freedom fighters
includes squanchy who if you listen
closely when it cuts off screen offers a
suggestion
and one of their backpacks has an
anti-federation patch now young memory
rix portal gun is constructed solely
from bp's memory of it which is why it
looks so crappy and why it cannot
actually create portals just these
rubbery discs but they smartly use that
as a shield later since bp's mine would
make these discs so that nothing could
pass through them rick says cool time to
save this cat save the cat is a
screenwriting term for when you make the
hero show his good nature by having him
save a defenseless creature early on in
the story that he doesn't really need to
save which in this case it's a bit
ironic because rick should care about
his best friend bird person but this is
rick's way of saying that he doesn't
really care this is just saving the cat
for him to try to make him look like a
good person phoniness that bird person
later calls out at the end of the
episode and the crate that rick steals
the pants from is labeled with a pants
icon it's just a box for spare pants
bibi observes a memory of his date with
tani i enjoy grains though have at times
been called a seed man i've certainly
enjoyed your seed
don't be gross tammy yeah this was bird
person's response to tammy in the past
what what am i eating what is this bird
seed it is random debris i found it in
my carpet i don't know what humans eat
you know what this human eats don't be
gross tammy
in historic childhood trauma town
members of bird person's race are
occupied by gromplomites one kicks over
what looks like an elder or spiritual
leader explaining what led bird person
to join rick's anti-federation crusade
against her grompton lights young memory
rick gets shot and asks can we both die
in here are we damaging our friend's
brain i i don't know any of the rules
not to the shifting logic of movies like
eternal sunshine and inception movie
that also called out its own confusing
rules midway through the battle of those
projections he's a part of his
subconscious yes
are you destroying those parts of his
mind no no they're just projections ah
the kind of crystalline i'll explain
along the way line that you know dan
harmon just loves have you seen
interteller no is that that christopher
nolan guy yeah dan doesn't seem to like
his films meanwhile the garage ai chats
with gene the next-door neighbor who has
been brought up in recent episodes he
compares her to jarvis and iron man
which the ai assumes should be enough
for them to be best friends yet another
example of the rick and morty writers
room mocking the mcu that so many of
their alumni are now working in maybe a
nod to the fact that jarvis started as a
disembodied ai but ended up in the body
of a tragic romantic figure who keeps
dying in people's memories another not
the fact that this could be diane look
on days when i'm staring intently at the
screen trying to spot a missable detail
or examining the micro expressions of my
co-workers on zoom i noticed my eyes
feel a bit heavy and i can have some
problems sleeping that's because blue
light from screens damages our eyes and
leads to digital eye strain which by the
way sorry about that symptoms of digital
eye strain include blurred vision
headaches dry watery eyes for some folks
this could even affect your energy level
well thanks to blue box for sponsoring
this video blue blocks was created to
fix this problem and they block out the
blue light with these high quality
lenses blue blocks are evidence-backed
and made under optics laboratory
conditions in australia the founders
were unhappy with the quality behind
leading blue light blocking glasses
brand so they made their own they have
over 40 styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers and they have frames for every
need just go to blueblocks.com
newrockstars20 or click the link below
and you will get 20 off your order and
get free shipping worldwide on orders
over 115 get your energy back sleep
better and block out the unhealthy
effects of blue light with blue blocks
that's b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash newrockstars20 or just
click the link below code automatically
apply to checkout for 20 off
rick and young memory rig talk about
shrek so he's just a grumpy scottish
ogre and they made four of them five by
now probably now if young memory rick
had not yet joined the c-137 reality
where beth was still alive before that
got cronenberg and he came from a
meeting where they talked about heading
toward bloodridge based on bird person's
line earlier then together we will make
our stand at blood ridge that would
place bloodridge historically sometime
before 2001 when the first shrek was
released oh by the way bloodridge was
mentioned on bb's wedding day you know
you're not being very supportive of a
bird person on his big day bird person's
big day morty was at blood ridge on glap
flap's third moon against the
gromphlomites and now we know another
reason why rick was drinking so heavily
in that moment not only was he losing
his best friend he was reminiscing on a
day his best friend already rejected him
now the core of bird person subconscious
is a crimson tree and inside there's a
gate framed by phoenix person s wings
since these are all the memories that
the federation suppressed when they made
him into a cyborg and inside is a
command center projecting a brain with
nodes reflecting those suppressed
memories similar to the still accessible
star memories when rick first went
inside bird person's mind there are
giant tanks containing negative emotions
labeled denial pain blame rage cringe
fear trauma disdain and repression maybe
like the nine pillars of
self-destruction in bird person's mind
per person uses these to fuel bombs in
order to self-destruct his mind from the
inside out i just love all this inside
out level world building one of the most
sophisticated designs i've seen in a
rick and morty episode it's just a shame
it goes by so fast for people to
appreciate it but i guess that's what
i'm here for i got you covered rick says
at this point i'd support you joining
scientology i'll take the workshops with
you i'll get into sauna with travolta i
don't even care what happens he is
referencing um suspicion that maybe the
reason john travolta won't come out
against the church of scientology is
that the church might have some
information on him i'm not gonna say
anymore i don't wanna get sued now on
the screen behind rig is up up down down
left left right right be a star which is
similar to the konami cheat code on nes
except that should be left right left
right i'm not really sure here maybe you
could read it as bird person doesn't
know the right code for it which is why
he's not giving himself extra bonus
lives he's just ending it right now
young memory rick sees the suppressed
memory of tammy turning on bird person
at their wedding and shot him in their
sweetheart nest
yeah they're using the same audio from
that moment the season two finale and i
like how it's hidden in a room like how
an inception dicaprio stacks his dark
memories in rooms that are accessed by
an elevator another suppressed memory is
bird person and tammy's child whom rick
later uses to change per person's mind
it's got a little mobile with a bird and
other insects birds would eat another
memory shows rick and phoenix person's
battle in the season 4 finale right
before his wings charge up and blast
rick but rick and refeers with this
memory seemingly just to steal his
memory's clothes but also i think to
erase this suppressed memory of phoenix
person calling him a bad friend after
rick admitted he had wondered about them
fighting all the time which might have
been a little moment that rick had
regretted as bird person's subconscious
scrambles his projections turn hostile
kind of like how an inception when
projections turn on the invasive
presence when the dream reality begins
to collapse they enter a ptsd station
well where's that go
that's the battle of blood ridge that's
our vietnam your values are wrong which
rick says because his ptsd comes not
from the horrors of war but from his
best friend rejecting his friendship in
this battle their transport is bombed
similar to the drop ship getting bombed
at the start of the battle and edge of
tomorrow lived i repeat great movie
check it out and as rick said at the
wedding we actually see this battle go
down we see some grafflabians in a war
against the gromplomites squanchy takes
his pill to juice up into a monster as
we saw him do with the wedding but
listen closely to this awesome
electronic music
[Music]
yeah you might recognize that that's a
synthy cover of the main rick and morty
title theme just an interesting way of
showing how the rick and morty show
we've been watching is actually a sequel
to rick and bird person rick asked per
person to join him in multiversal
adventures and he's got a makeshift
portal gun once again because bp's mind
doesn't remember it exactly i could take
you right now to this same battlefield
in a universe where we lost or another
where we won or another where the war
never even happened all equally real all
equally unreal none of it matters this
actually mirrors the pitch that
alternate rick made in that season 3
flashback imagine doing anything you
want then hopping to a timeline where
you never did it imagine going anywhere
anytime with nobody able to stop you
sounds lonely and rick's response there
was just like bird person's response
here a life of infinite possibility
sounds great but it also makes
everything meaningless and a bit lonely
bird person says if you need me use the
beacon referencing how when rick used a
beacon to bring bird person to the party
in season one when we first met bird
person the beacon was activated who was
in danger now when bp calls rick sad
young memory rick defends him you don't
get to tell anyone what's sad man you're
like a one man mount sadmore so i guess
like a lincoln sad morial i guess it's
interesting to consider the lincoln
memorial being a sad lonely version of
mount rushmore but either way forcing
the word sad in there gets young memory
rick a judging stare from tammy that
lasts an awkward amount of time after
convincing a person to live using the
idea of his daughter they flee and on
their way out they pass this wooden jet
cart i guess because all the things in
bird person's mind must be things that
are bird related or things that fly and
they crash into a memory of rick's
garage uh the night we met gross on my
workbench quan she used that's what some
closets are for i call back to the
season one finale party where bird
person and tammy met bird person is
referring to when morty discover
squanchy squanching in the closet rick
retrieves a plumbus the all-purpose home
device from the interdimensional cable
commercial the device he's looking for
is the mind blower this was used to suck
out memories and put them in liquid
vials in the season 3 episode evil tammy
says rick sanchez you're under arrest
for making me spend two years in earth
high school similar to how rick's
biggest gripe about tammy was you made
me go to a wedding
and you killed my best friend i should
have said that one first rick blows his
memory of gear dude's funeral and uses
the liquid vial to form a portal to the
memory which he plans to use to lily pad
to the exit point and gear dude has a
latin funeral on gear world where we
meet a younger version of gear head
established as gear dude's younger
brother the only reason they hung out
with that lame guy they go through the
market where you can see unlock your
inner gear mystic gears and gear adelies
and they visit squanchy's terrible
stand-up phase the club here is bird
flappers flappers being a burbank comedy
club where i too have been invited to
watch friends going through their
stand-up phases and yeah nice pun here
birds clap i just think it's clever how
they need something performance-based in
order to link back to their concert
performance at the fest the origin of
their band the flesh curtains that was
actually referenced in graffiti a few
episodes back they escaped back to the
surface rick and bird person 100 years
of course a callback to rick's drunken
rant to morty in the pilot episode but
another sign that rick and brid person
was truly the predecessor to this show
but bird person calls out rick's
selfishness and telling him about his
daughter which was only to save himself
which now if you think about it saddles
bird person with abandonment guilt which
has always cursed rick when it's come to
beth and now forcing bird person to care
for this violent psychopath as we see in
the post-credits scene in bird culture
this is considered a dick move and back
in kid rick's bedroom notice how he
looks and dresses a lot like morty
there's also a drawing for his future
spaceship car and he sleeps in a car bed
just like how i believe his car is now
voiced by someone he used to sleep with
convince me otherwise actually don't i'm
probably wrong there you can support new
rock stars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
a few weeks for the finale bye
[Music]
you